we just had to do more Vogon because
we're so nostalgic about the character
first of all we really wanted to see
where Corvo felt like with a voice every
year I think the anniversary of Jessa
means death will be easier but it never
is in dishonor to its 15 years after the
rat plague after the first game and
Corvo is wondering how long can I
protect my daughter
who's seen a lot still facing these
crazy threats to the throne and to the
Empire
and so Corvo is like a man reflecting on
the winter of his life he's both the the
badass supernatural assassin we wanted
him to be and he's very thoughtful and
of course Corvo is a foreigner that's
part of his character he's originally
from surco nose at the start of dishonor
- he's on the run from the mall tower
this time he's going down into his
native country he's seeing surco nose
again for the first time in a long time
he's seeing how it's changed under the
new Scirocco nose and so it's a land
that's familiar to him and unfamiliar at
the same time kaho comes back all his
spoils and what we wanted to do is not
only put them in the new engine but also
finds interesting tweaks or improvement
to them it's interesting to look at
corvo's powers he was a guy who was
marked by the outsider during the rat
plague and then half the city was dead
by plague and so he has devourer next
one you can now upgrade it so that you
have two swarms of rats and larger
swarms of rats you're gonna have a swarm
that follows you around Pied Piper style
and those are just some of the upgrades
under the Valerie swarm he's also a
foreigner he's from a different place
and he never quite fit in in dunwall so
he has the power of possession we can
literally embody someone else and walk
around in their skin you know the
position it's this ability that allows
you to to physically enter a character
or an animal at first and exits
somewhere else so you actually use the
character or the animal as a vessel to
move through the world and we added some
upgrades that allow you for instance to
chain hosts another cool kind of weird
upgrades that you now allowed to possess
corpses if you choose this upgrade
suddenly it's not about movements it's
about creating hiding spots for yourself
each time you knock some
one down or you kill him it becomes a
hiding place
one of corvo's classic powers that fans
absolutely love because it's so crazy
over the top is Bend time initially he
has the ability to slow time and then he
can upgrade it so you can stop time
altogether this time we also allow you
to spool time for it a little bit
pressing a button or pulling a trigger
you can allow it to advance a little bit
until things get exactly in the position
that you want it's very powerful one of
Corbeau signature powers from the first
game is blink it's sort of a short-range
teleport when we were working on DLC for
Dishonored one we gave doubt a kind of a
redirected blink that allows you to move
out into space stop time rotate and
continue blink back in the direction you
came or in another direction and so we
knew that's one upgrade we wanted to add
to core go for from blink in the new
game it really does allow players to
explore their environment it's not only
about spending the power but expanding
them in a way that is fun that's allows
for that kind of creative play plus the
new system for the supernatural powers
were to give upgrades for all of them
and allow the player to go deeper on
those and explore those mechanics and
how they interact with stealth in combat
situations players are really gonna be
torn the new thing with Emily or the
nostalgic thing with Corvo right now if
you asked me to choose between the two I
would be hard pressed because I love
them both like that it's like choosing
between your children